l'arrivée se voulait triomphal après
s'être posé sans encombre l'avion
transportant les membres du nouveau
gouvernement yéménite s'immobilise
devant une foule de partisans
l'appareil provient de ryad où les
autorités du yémen vit en exil depuis
2014 à la suite de l'offensive des
outils alors que les membres de ce
nouvel exécutif se prépare à descendre
sur le tarmac
la cérémonie est interrompue
des coups de feu une première explosion
retentit ce tandis que la foule se
disperse dans la panique
quelques instants plus tard une deuxième
explosion survient
[Musique]
une épaisse fumée noire s'élèvent alors
dans le ciel après avoir repris le
contrôle de la situation le gouvernement
communique tous ses membres sont inde m
mais plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont
été tuées ou blessées les dégâts
matériels sont considérables
dans une allocution le premier ministre
yéménite dénonce un acte terroriste
c'est un acte terroriste lâche cela mais
le gouvernement face à ses
responsabilités
c'est à dire mettre fin au coup d'état
reprendre le contrôle du pouvoir et
répandre la stabilité dans notre pays
même si le chef du gouvernement yéménite
ne les nomme pas son ministre de
l'information accuse les outils d'avoir
mené cette attaque en attentat qui
survient alors que le fragile pouvoir
yéménite s'est enfin dotée d'un nouvel
exécutif d'union le 18 décembre dernier
cette nouvelle équipe va tenter de
reprendre le contrôle d'un pays ravagé
par cinq ans de guerre entre la
coalition dirigée par l'arabie saoudite
et les outils face à ces insurgés
soutenus par l'iran
les coups de boutoir des saoudiens
épaulés par leurs alliés les forces
gouvernementales restent vains pour
prendre l'ascendant ryad a négocié un
accord avec les séparatistes du sud du
pays
une alliance qui ne leur a pas encore
permis de reprendre le contrôle des
territoires tenus par les outils la
guerre au yémen à plonger ce pays dans
la pire crise humanitaire au monde selon
les nations unies